oh when you create events that are well
covered it slowly starts getting bigger
so I think this is the start of
something big well the Grand Chester is
sort of combining some of the top
tournaments together it's three
tournaments it's sort of like a grand
prix the the combined score of the three
tournaments will factor into the final
standings the difference with the with a
grand chat sewer versus a normal one off
event is that it's a combination of
three events and there are prizes
overall based on how you do an all three
events so certainly you don't want to do
bat badly in any of the events which I
think speaks to trying to perform with a
high level of consistency I think it's
important that the top tournaments are
eventually part of a professional cycle
and I think this is a good start I like
that its innovative I think we need to
try new things in chess and I really
hope that they succeed with this grand
chest or concept in in general when
people who love chess unite and
one of those people is obviously mr.
cinq-cinq felt it only does good for
chess and I think this whole idea of a
grand slam if the blossoms which I'm
sure will can really promote our sport
in media and also among the youngsters